The solution set includes negative 3, negative 1, positive 3 and positive 1.
Four separate answers. Great work if you found these four. And keep in mind, we
should have these four answers, since we have a 4 for our highest power. We can
make the substitution u to equal m squared. We know this since m squared
squared equals m to the fourth. This let's us have a power of two here and a
power of 1 here on the us. Next, we factor this quadratic expression to get u
minus 9 times u minus 1. We set each of these factors equal to zero to get u
equals 9 and u equals positive 1. Now we're ready to go back and find the
original values for m. We use u equals 9 and u equals 1 from the two solutions
we found from factoring. We know u really equals m squared. So for this u,
we'll have m squared equals 9 and for this u, we'll have m squared equals 1. We
want to solve for m, so we take the square root of both sides of the equations.
So here we'll have m equals plus or minus 3 and here we'll have m equal to plus
or minus 1. So we'll have negative 3, positive 3, negative 1 and positive 1 as
our solution set.